dernier coup de rouge dernier coup de
rouge c'est à dire
bonjour je m'appelle Thierry Ardisson
j'ai décidé de poser aux gens les
questions que je posais au stade
dernier coup dur la mort du père de mon
meilleur ami dernier coup dur c'était le
covid financièrement ça a été très
compliqué c'est dur de voir où on est
descendu au niveau culture il y en a
plus sur la tête on a crânien agression
d'un coup de tête jouer du piano devant
la mer et donc j'ai installé un super
cramer London devant la mer je suis venu
ici c'est un voyageur clandestin à mes
frères dernier coup de cœur toujours ma
femme ça fait 36 ans
ça fait longtemps c'est mon petit fils
ma petite fille voilà c'est dernier coup
de poing c'est tous les jours on parle
beaucoup de l'Ukraine mais on parle pas
de l'Arménie au boulot tout le temps
j'ai mal aux mains jamais dernier coup
de folie dernier coup de folie c'est
qu'on se travaillait à mon compte ça
c'était
la folie une belle bague j'adore les
chaussures il montre j'adore dernier
coup de gueule ah ben non les transports
en commun ah bah moi c'est souvent déjà
qui parle fort qui me casse les oreilles
contre la ville Paris et puis qui
balance des trucs par terre les
embouteillages dernier coup de foudre
c'est la mère de mes gosses
[Musique]
c'était encore tout à l'heure là avec
quelqu'un qui vient de me tromper je
règle mes comptes
rouges chez moi tranquille j'ai une cave
aujourd'hui un primitivo un vin
dépouilles je sais pas plutôt rouge je
suis plutôt blanc c'est pas plus tard
que hier oh ben c'était hier soir j'aime
bien le Vinci hier soir parce qu'il se
présente oui bah si c'est du très bon
c'est du très bon mais si c'est de le
piquet on voit quand même d'aller coup
de blues j'en ai pas eu ça récemment là
avant-hier j'en ai pas j'en ai pas
dernier coup de boule c'est mon patron
mon ex patron qui s'est pris une tarte
dans la gueule il avait qu'à pas sortir
sa tête en réunion voilà
et une dizaine de jours mec arrêtait pas
de s'épancher sur facebook
malheureusement j'ai trouvé son adresse
la politique coup de boule dans le
jardin
contre un ex toujours dernier coup de
raté j'en sais rien
si longtemps et 9 mois un mois et demi
parce que j'ai décidé de ne plus faire
de coudre en Europe c'est plutôt en
Afrique que ça agréable bon il y a une
semaine tu pars pour de vrai
mon talon
on est mercredi on est jeudi mardi oui
il faut quand même s'entretenir un peu
c'était ce weekend au mois dernier coup
de rein c'était un coup de main physique
en son du ménage par exemple j'aime pas
faire
[Musique]